whitney good morning how are we doing
good how are you
thanks for having me i'm good thank you
so much for calling
so what's up so i
am a stay-at-home mom of four amazing
little boys
my oldest is seven and my youngest is
nineteen months can we just stop for a
second
can we stop brazilian whoa that's a lot
that is a lot especially during covert
good for you
oh you're a hero all right so how can i
help
um so my husband attempted suicide in
september
oh my gosh i'm so sorry yeah thank you
um it was extremely violent okay when
the kids and i were home
and you know i'm confused and angry
and so my main question is how can i
remain
supportive through my confusion and my
anger and to even take it further
how could i ever trust him again or
trust myself with him again
[Music]
wow that's a lot yeah was it out of the
blue has he been showing signs of
depression for a long time walk me
through
what led up to this okay so
um i mean for me initially
before i went and did some digging as
you may understand i was trying to look
for my why
yeah um but for me it looked like a
really
hard quick downward spiral okay but i'm
starting to understand that this must
have been
a longer path for him right a longer
path of
depression anxiety and probably sleep
deprivation
really um but he he never seemed to be
satisfied with where he was in his
career
and he never got the success that we had
both hoped for
so about a little over three years ago
he started his own business
and in january of last year actually
this year
this past january he got what i would
call his big break
we were finally financially comfortable
um able to do the things that we wanted
and something happened at work um
starting like at the end of june i don't
really know the details of it all but
i'm trying to figure that out hopefully
it comes out more as he goes through
his recovery but um i started seeing
him change and he towards the end
in september he's he was like a walking
zombie a shell of himself
he wasn't sleeping he was super paranoid
and
i saw this and i tried to get him help
um i actually he ended up going to um
an inpatient hospital and they released
him in three days they really just kind
of threw medication at him
and released them and that was it okay
and that was when he was released he was
released on monday of labor day
that was labor day um that whole week he
i could tell
nothing had changed and he he was still
in a really bad place so
i had set up an outpatient program for
him to start monday september 14th
and on the 13th is when it happened okay
and when you say he survived has he got
all his faculties
is he is he recovered physically
um he was in the hospital for a month
and he
still is whispering only a whisper we
don't know if he'll ever
speak normally again okay um but
i mean physically he's he's recovering
yeah he's he's now i actually
you know moved mountains to get him to a
facility in florida
because the georgia mental health is a
little tough um i really wanted a whole
program that could
he could be at for a while and really
figure out what was going on
okay so he's he's getting the help he
needs but and i want to be supportive
and i want him to get healthy he's a
good dad he's a good person there's not
one person that will
ever say anything bad about him so this
is very
shocking yeah um
so before we get into your heart on this
deal
what did your boys see
did they experience this trauma too
firsthand or they just in the room
obviously when you were experiencing
this
and the flashing lights and all that
yeah
so they i mean i'm so thankful they were
outside we were all
we were supposed to go to the pool so i
was getting them ready to go to the pool
outside and i was actually having his
parents come
and sit with him because i saw something
kind of switch in him and suddenly he
didn't want to go to the pool
um and actually i should probably tell
you that
he he started cutting himself
two weeks prior to this happening and
what switched in him was when he changed
into his bathing suit i saw more cuts on
his leg and i kind of was like
oh my god what what are you when did you
do that
and some i saw something switch in him
i called his parents and i was like well
now i have to take the kids to the pool
they're so excited they've
been waiting to go can you sit with him
and he only went inside for a minute
to put you know a toy on the counter and
the kids were still in the garage
outside
and the second that door shut i was like
oh my gosh
he's he's alone i i asked my son to go
scream for daddy hey come outside come
outside and when he said he wasn't
answering
i just told my oldest day with the stay
with them don't
move stay in the driveway and i ran
inside
and broke down a locked bathroom door to
find him
so i want to um start walking
again they didn't they didn't see
anything they only saw the you know the
emergency
cars they saw the police cars the fire
engines so
that's all they saw so that's a lot
and if you haven't already they need to
um have somebody that they can talk to
a registered play therapist who knows
what they're doing
who can slowly integrate trauma
into their life and they will
this will play back in different ways
differently with each one of those boys
but i would strongly recommend you've
got somebody in that community a good
play therapist that can walk through
that with them
and they pick up way way way more than
you think they do
and the damaging thing for kids
is they pick up that tension they pick
up those flashing lights they pick up
mommies crying they pick up mommy's
pacing back and forth all of the adults
all the casseroles showing up
and they register that they had
something to do with that
and that manifests itself in all sorts
of
ping pong ways all throughout their life
and so we call it trauma integration it
is a part of their life
and they 100 can heal from it and in
fact they can heal from it in ways that
make them
super resilient and a gift to anyone who
runs into them for the rest of their
life
but it's got to be appropriately
integrated otherwise it will come out in
all sorts of
wild ways and so you didn't call me for
for advice on them but my head
always goes to the children first okay
they picked way more of this up than you
probably think they did and you've been
doing the lord's work trying to shield
them from this and protect them from
this
um but they are able to at whatever
cellular level
put together mommy screaming and blood
and flashing lights and daddy's not home
and that will they will do an algorithm
in their head that just doesn't add up
right and that they are the
at the other end of that equal sign and
so find a play therapist for them
and then for you i don't know if
anyone's told you this and i hope they
have but if they haven't
you saw something that nobody is
supposed to see and i'm sorry
i think i'm working with someone i'm not
good you are not supposed to see that
and i'm sorry that you did
and i've seen too much of that and i
wasn't supposed to see it
and i'm proud of you for doing the hard
work of going to see somebody
so here's a couple of things just to
wrap your head around and again
hopefully people have told you this and
so i'm telling you this and the listener
here
um suicide's not something that
is done by cowardly folks right
and it's not something that somebody
does to
on a whim generally um the fact that you
saw those cuts
suggest two things right thomas joyner
is dr joyner's one of the
the most extraordinary suicidologists
they call him in the country
and he has a couple of prongs for
how people can finally get to this place
where they believe
the world is better off without them and
that they are hurting so bad that this
is the only solution right
and that is number one this idea that
they are lonely
and not only are they lonely but their
presence is a burden to other people and
this idea that they can actually do it
and so often cutting isn't a big deal
and it usually
shocks people when i say that but there
is
evidence to where sometimes cutting is
people practicing
the ability to hurt themselves they are
leaning into this because that's a
really
difficult thing for for the human body
to do to itself right
um and i want you to know that it wasn't
your fault and in fact he's alive
because of you right
so how do you trust him again it's going
to be a long road
and i wish there was an easy answer to
that but there's not going to be
it's going to be hard for you to trust
him it's going to be hard for you to
leave
his and your kids with him
it's going to be hard to fully lean up
against that guy
who's been fighting and clawing for his
family for all these years
and the good dad of your boys it's going
to be hard
and it's going to be something i want
you to keep this word in your head it's
gonna be something that you're gonna
have
to
practice you're gonna have to practice
trusting
it's not something that's just gonna
come back magically when
he gets out of
his program and he's medically healed
and he is at least safe enough where he
can go back and
um be at home then the next step
is going to be y'all going to a great
marriage therapist with some trauma
background
and y'all are gonna have to rebuild your
relationship
from scratch yeah
and you may have heard me say this on
this show often this is an analogy we
use
with couples who have experienced
infidelity somebody cheats on somebody
but it applies here too and that is
your old relationship is now gone
it's going to be on different footing
and so if you think about
they could never go back and get all of
the glass and dust
and steel and roofing tiles
that was the world trade center and get
all that dust back and rebuild those
with those original parts
what they had to do is excavate the
entire thing
and then they put out a bid for new
architectural drawings and they built
something that is stronger
it's able to withhold more and for some
it's a beacon of hope that will resound
in them forever
and so what you're going to have to do
is be committed to building something
new
not trying to duct tape and piece
together what y'all had because what you
had
is is now been disrupted right
right and so this is the journey you're
on and it's going to be
real normal for you to be angry to be
lonely
it's going to be normal for you to be
super frustrated just because you're
going to do bedtime by yourself with
those four boys
it's going to that all that stuff's
normal and you're gonna have to be real
real graceful
with yourself besides having somebody
that you're working with the therapist
you're working with do you have friends
in your community that you can be honest
honest and vulnerable with who
who are walking with you i do yeah i'm
lucky
okay really lucky well you may be lucky
but you may have cultivated it too right
for just a time such as this
right right right
so are you in it for the long haul
are you in it too i mean do you have it
in you to to rebuild
this thing i
don't know yet okay i feel like i'm in
an in-between
stage and i am supportive and i my goal
my first goal for him is to
for him to get healthy my second goal
would for
him to financially provide for his kids
again
because we have to put food on the table
and his job is gone
so i'm having not only to deal with the
kids but in sports and homework
you know yeah but finances all on my own
and then it would be you know he's got
to be a dad again
to these boys and then it would be the
marriage for me i mean i
i almost imagine that we need to
co-parent for a while first
because i just don't like right now and
i don't know how i'm going to feel six
months from now but right now
i can't imagine him walking into this
house and just
living here again why not
because i don't like i will start
looking at the kitchen knives and be
like oh my god
they're out like oh my like i just don't
i don't trust them but but also when i'm
talking to them and there is a family
therapist
with that speaks with both of us every
monday
from this facility okay so i speak to
him and you know he hasn't really made
any progress yet i know that
that it's a really long road and for me
i'm just looking for it to be faster but
i mean i so right now i just can't
imagine that he
is just going to be held like one day
he's going to be healthy right now i
can't see it
sure so i don't know
every time i look at a kitchen i have to
cut vegetables i think of him now that's
right
and that's that goes back to you
shouldn't have seen what you saw
right and that's where your healing's
gonna have to be
um a high priority for you and
what i wanna tell you is if you choose
to remain married to him
the way you just described the playback
will have to be inverted
meaning he can only do the work that
helps him be well
he has to be committed to being well he
has to be committed to
taking care of himself he's got to be
committed to
dealing with the darkness and the
depression and the burdensome
feelings he's got to deal with all that
but once he comes back
he can only and you can only move
forward with the co-parenting with the
honoring your kids and
anne through connection
right and the other part of it is that
when i did look for
why he did this or what happened i found
out that he had been lying to me for
some time
sure um so it was it's almost like he
was living a double life
so if he can't let me in and he can't be
vulnerable with me and he can't how am i
going to help them like how is it so
never going to work
i want you to do a real important thing
okay
and if you get nothing out of this phone
call i want you to do a real important
thing
how old your oldest little boy seven
seven so your little boy
comes in at 2 a.m and says mommy i don't
feel good
and you're in a haze and you wake up and
you're like what honey and he says mommy
i don't feel good
and then he just barfs all over your bed
that's gross it's super frustrating and
annoying
but you can't get mad at him because he
did the only thing he could do
in that moment that he came to his mom
the one safe place that he knows and
then his body was sick
and so right now i you're you're gonna
wear yourself
out moralizing what happened to your
husband
you've got to transition that thought to
my husband's sick
and if it helps you to imagine he was in
a car wreck
if it happened if it helps you to
imagine he's got
some sort of cardiovascular disease or
something so be it
but your husband's sick
he didn't do this to get at you he
didn't do this
to ruin your life
no more than your seven-year-old son
wouldn't do that just so you'd have to
do extra laundry
okay your husband's sick he's not well
and when you get frustrated and when you
get angry
it's easy to go get inside of his head
and try to figure out why he did this
and why he didn't do this
but the reality is he made some bad
decisions on top of
some messy brain chemistry on top of
probably a bunch of
childhood trauma plus he didn't have the
tools to walk through it and reach
across
that aisle to you and say help he was
sick
right and so you are simply gonna weigh
yourself down carrying around your anger
at him
it's normal but i'm just telling you
you're going to bury yourself he is off
in a facility somewhere it's not going
to help him
he's not going to quote unquote get any
message from your anger and your
frustration
okay and so what i want to ask you to do
today
is make a commitment whether you write
him an angry letter
whether you
write down my husband was sick on a
piece of paper
or put it on a brick and carry it around
for a little bit and then just set that
down
you carrying around just pissed off at
him
for ruining everything is understandable
but it's just
crushing you and that's not true it's
not crushing just you it's crushing your
kids too
and that's a non-fear an unfair
statement that i'm giving you but i just
want to give you the reality you're
hurting your kids too
put it down set it down
what you saw is unimaginable what you
are experiencing is unimaginable
what you are having to pivot and do
life was going one way in january and
all of a sudden it's going a totally
different direction
not by your hand but in your lap
put down your hatred and your anger and
your frustration at him
at your disbelief at him he's sick
continue to walk with people who love
you continue to walk forward with your
trauma therapist
continue to show up to those monday
family sessions
and lean in as best as you can
and put the anger and the hatred down
i would love it whitney if you would
call continue to call
every couple of weeks let us know how
you're doing let us know how the
therapy's going
and we will continue to think about you
and be
in prayer for you as you walk this
journey
it's going to be a long journey and the
the least amount of baggage you've got
carrying with you the better